Lisa bloom the famous feminist lawyer
has proved this perfectly but it's not
really about the Tara Reid stuff because
the Joe Biden does have a point it's
been 27 years and it's strange that
these things are just coming up now
should they be investigated yeah sure I
suppose so they're far more credible
than the Brett Kavanaugh allegations I
have a far more sympathetic view of the
accuser in this case than any of the
feminists do so surely we should at
least take it seriously but it's not
just the terror Reid stuff it's his
whole career and he says no we can't
look at that he's actually kind of
agreeing with me saying yeah if we're
not that worried about the allegation
we're worried about my whole career he
goes on and unbelievable you got to give
it to Joe Biden he somehow makes a bad
defense even worse when he says forget
even about my public papers what about
all the contacts I've had with foreign
governments what about my conversations
with Barack Obama that I had about those
foreign governments why not do it for
both sets of Records because the
material in the University of Delaware
has no personnel files it has but it
does have a lot of confidential
conversations that I had with the
president about a particular issue that
I had with the heads of state of other
places that that would not be something
that would be revealed while I was in
public office or while I was seeking
public office you had a lot of
conversations with President men
President Barack Obama about a
particular issue and on this issue you
also had conversations with heads of
state what might that particular issue
be with that particular issue be the
actual biggest scandal of your recent
campaign the issue that while you were
vice president running relations with
the Ukraine you insisted that the
prosecutor who was investigating your
crooked son get fired in exchange for
aid from the United States would it
would it be that on this issue of
Ukraine and Hunter Biden and burries m'j
that that clip where you said we're
gonna withhold the funding if you don't
fire this guy I'll call Barack Obama
right now would it be you know that
clipping is kind of floating around
would that be the issue maybe is that
the issue that you don't want to come up
I don't know I'm just raising questions
I haven't seen the files but it sure as
hell seems to me that we should Biden
taking a bad particular situation which
is this increasingly credible allegation
against him although we don't know that
it is actually credible right don't
forget it still took decades for this
thing to come out story has changed a
little bit far more credible than
Christine Blasi Ford but let's not get
ahead of ourselves here right he's
taking this bad problem for his campaign
and turning it into a much broader
problem that reflects on his own
corruption and his own political
weaknesses and then he gets to the worst
clip the most Awkward clip of the entire
interview so I've got to warn you when
you listen to Joe Biden's response on
this there's gonna be a pause your audio
has not gone out the podcast has not
stopped
it's just that awkward what's funny
about this is that it's actually Joe
Biden's best defense but he couldn't
give it right classic Joe Biden move so
Mika asks if there's nothing there in
the records why not do a search I'm just
talking about her name not anybody else
in those records a search for that
nothing classified I'd be a president or
anybody else I'm just asking why not do
a search for Tara Reid's name in the
University of Delaware records look I
mean who does that search the University
of Delaware
perhaps you set up a commission that can
do it I don't know whatever is the
fairest way to create the most
transparency well this is look mica
she said she filed a report she has her
employment records still she said she
filed a report with the only office that
wouldn't have a report in the United
States Senate at the time if the report
was ever filed it was filed there period
he finally got around to it it's their
period it's all over but not before that
long awkward pause this is Joe Biden's
best defense as to why he doesn't want
to open up his sealed records at the
University of Delaware and that defenses
who's gonna do the search we're in the
midst of a presidential campaign nobody
could possibly be without some kind of
interest here without some kind of bias
so we just can't do it is nobody would
have the objectivity to do it if the
Biden campaign did the search no one
would believe it if the University of
Delaware did the search it might leak
and still perhaps no one would believe
it if some other political operatives
are brought in it would be too
unreliable and too dangerous and other
candidates actually wouldn't do it but
Joe Biden can't get this out there so
Joe Biden just destroys himself as
always as he always does just his
campaign gets worse and worse and worse
all on his own Nicole Wallace mainstream
media reporter MSNBC decides that it's
not Joe Biden's own fault it's not Mika
Brzezinski zone fault it's not Tara
Reid's fault you're not technically
allowed to blame Tara Reid even though
that's what the Democrats are trying to
do she's saying that this whole ask this
whole aspect of the attack on Joe Biden
is a smear campaign being run by
Republicans I think that this
a year without campaigns without a
campaign trail without a campaign press
corps and the silver lining if you will
is that voters are gonna have to watch
that interview this morning and and make
their own judgments about there are no
more arbiters there are no more poobahs
in either party let me just say this to
having once been a part of the
Republican Party the right isn't running
an intellectually honest operation to
get to the bottom of whether Tara Reid
was victimized the right is running a
smear campaign against Joe Biden
it's a smear campaign being run by the
right it's being run by the right really
I thought it was being run by Tara Reid
who is a Democrat who isn't just a
Democrat she's a democratic staffer who
worked for Joe Biden that's what it is
and by the way Republicans have been
actually pretty less a fair about this
whole thing we haven't totally embraced
the Tara Reid stuff we're pointing out
the hypocrisy of how Kavanaugh was
treated versus how Biden's being treated
by the media but we're not totally
embracing it actually here's my evidence
President Trump is sort of defending Joe
Biden is a brilliant totally unexpected
but a brilliant move President Trump was
on Dan bungee knows podcast just a
couple days ago and he was asked about
the Tara Reid allegations and you ask
yourself how's Trump gonna respond is he
gonna go hard after Joe and call him a
creepy sexual assailant is he going to
stay out of the fray or this is the
bizarre option is he going to defend Joe
Biden and actually defending Joe Biden
was politically the smartest move I've
been falsely accused by people that I've
never even seen I've never even seen
many of these people and some of them I
met him zero interest okay like zero and
all of a sudden you become a wealthy guy
you're a famous guy then you become
president and people just people that
you've never seen that you've never
heard of make charges so you know I
guess in a way you could say I'm I'm
sticking up for him but the mother was
very compelling certainly and the
girlfriend or the friends were very
compelling and certainly far more
compelling than anything
they had with respect to Brett Kavanaugh
this is one of the most high-quality
human beings what they did to that
family and that man is a disgrace so
Scott Adams the Dilbert guy gave some
good analysis of this a few other people
have as well but Scott's is worth
checking out Trump is in a very tough
spot here right because if Trump goes
after Joe based on these allegations as
some creepy sexual assailant well look
Donald Trump has been a Playboy for much
of his career and so you can always
dredge up a bunch of people who were
calling him some kind of sexual asylum
none with the credibility of Tara Reid
against Joe Biden right you always hear
this from the left they say there's 20
accusations of sexual misconduct against
Trump 25 50 million accusations of
sexual misconduct the way that you know
that there aren't really 20 serious
allegations of sexual misconduct against
Trump is if any of them were really
credible the mainstream media would not
have shut up about it for the last four
years but they don't have any actual
credible allegations against Trump
so they trot out a porn star that he had
a completely consensual relationship
with remember stormy Daniels they used
that for like a year or two years if
they had someone who actually said that
guy raped me that guy assaulted me then
we would know her name right but you
never hear the names just you're all
it's 20 it's 25 women so Trump still
knows that he's not going to be treated
fairly in the media and so he takes this
really reasonable position which is look
we don't know if these claims are true
famous people famous men do get targeted
with false allegations this has happened
a lot we don't know if the allegations
are true or not against Joe the only
thing we know is that the left and the
media are being completely hypocritical
here this is the same argument this is
the by far the best argument that
conservatives could possibly make and it
leaves the left no wiggle room right
they've tried to put us in an impossible
position we turn it around and put them
in that position Lisa bloom Gloria
Allred's daughter Lisa bloom one of the
most famous feminist lawyers in the
country took this she was in this
impossible position and she took it to
its logical conclusion I
that this tweet from Lisa bloom will be
cited by sociologists as the precise
moment that feminism died she tweets out
unbelievable
I believe you Tara Reid you have people
who remember you told them about this
decades ago
we know he is handsy you're not asking
for money
you've obviously struggled mightily with
this I still have to fight Trump so I
still support Jo but I believe you and
I'm sorry that is a stunning statement
from the feminist left and it confirms
everything we have said about them from
the beginning which is this is not about
supporting women this is not about the
objective pursuit of truth this is not
about fighting the oppressors and
helping the oppressed or whatever
language they use this is about
attacking conservatives this is about
attacking our culture which
conservatives obviously want to conserve
the me2 movement has gone from believe
all women in 2016 to now in 2020 believe
all women and elect their rapists that's
what she's saying she's saying I believe
that Joe Biden is a sexual asal --nt I
believe it I believe everything you're
claiming is true and I'm sorry but I'm
definitely still gonna vote for him at
least Lisa bloom is honest she's
catching a lot of flak for this because
what she's saying is indefensible but
the whole feminist left is indefensible
no they just lie and they try to be
hypocrites at least at least what Lisa
bloom is doing is admitting what this is
ahead of the times up you know the
time's up me too organization kind of
times up is defending Biden too
disbelieving Reed same thing with Debra
Messing the famous leftist actress same
thing with Alyssa Milano some people are
shocked by the double standard I am NOT
okay this was never about principles not
the me2 movement not feminism not any of
the leftist social movements that we've
seen over the last hundred years not any
part of leftism it's not about Prince
or standards it's about you it's about
tearing you down it's about taking away
your culture taking away your country
taking away your traditions and your
rituals or rich rituals or your rituals
your dialects that might pronounce
rituals as rituals you everything that
you cherish that you want to conserve
it's about tearing that down it's about
deconstruction right these are the kind
of words that you hear all the time from
the left deconstruction social
constructs and deconstruction right they
want to rip it down they don't like you
they don't like your culture they don't
like your traditions they don't like
your history they don't like your
civilization they want to tear it down
if feminism will tear it down they'll
use feminism if the hijab will tear it
down they'll use the hijab right they'll
use kind of Islamic identity politics
feminism and the hijab don't really go
together doesn't matter they'll use
whichever one's convenient if gay
identity politics will tear it down
they'll use that if transgender identity
politics will tear it down which totally
undermine gay identity politics all
right the whole idea of homosexual
identity politics is were born this way
there is such a thing as biological sex
we're attracted to people of the same
sex transgenderism says none of that's
true there is no such thing as sex
anyway we can be men can be women women
can be men it's transphobic if you're
not attracted to the people that I want
you to be attracted to doesn't matter
they'll use either one and we're
perpetually shocked that people like
Linda Sarsour right Islamists will hold
hands with Gloria Steinem leftist
secular feminists at the Women's March
we say these two people don't have a lot
in common but yet they hold hands at the
women's March they do have something in
common they have a common enemy and
that's you and your culture and your
civilization we're shocked that they
believe Christine Blasi Ford but not
Tara Reid why it's not about any
principle okay it's just about tearing
down the culture it is purely a politics
of opposition this is not even a
conflict of visions for the culture it's
about culture and it's about anti
culture and that's it and we should be
open eyed to it and stop being these
naive little children who are
perpetually shocked and we say yeah
but look at the hypocrisy they don't
care about the hypocrisy point out the
hypocrisy because it's important to win
over conservatives and moderates and
independence the left doesn't care it
was never about principles it was always
about you
[Music]